Speaker 1: Hey, guys, I don't know how Joe
Biden did this, but there are more people
working in the United States today than at
any previous time in the history of the country,
if you can believe that.
Obama now.
This is, of course, very tongue in cheek.
But it is also true if you're new to this
show, I really want you to pay special attention
to this segment because this is actually I
really want to do this the right way.
Okay.
We started seeing headlines late last week
like this one record number of Americans employed
in December, 159,244,000 record number of
Americans employed in December.
Now, this is one of my favorite political
footballs, depending on whether you want to
argue the economy is good or the economy is
bad for politically partizan reasons, you
can very often use phrases like there are
more Americans than ever currently working
or there are more Americans than ever currently
not working.
Or you can go away from the number and talk
about the percentage.
You can say the labor participation rate is
higher than ever or the rate is lower than
ever.
Okay.
This is all basically B.S. in a vacuum.
So let's really break down what's going on
here in the United States.
The population continues to increase.
And so if over time there is an average labor
participation rate, let's just call it 60%.
Okay.
One of the things that will be true is that
the number of people working and the number
of people not working will both be at record
highs.
Think through the numbers.
It's very simple.
In a country of 100 million people with a
60% labor participation rate, you would have
60 million people working and 40 million people
not working.
Great.
Time goes by.
You get to 200 million people in the population.
That's 60%.
Labor participation rate now means, wow, we
have 120 million people working.
We have a record number of people working,
but we also have 80 million people not working.
We have a record number of people not working.
Is the economy good or is the economy bad?
I don't know.
Depends who, what, what point you want to
make or what you want to justify.
So it's not actually a great indicator of
how the economy is doing.
But what's ironic, what's funny, what's interesting
is that Republicans love to take either the
number of people working or the labor participation
rate out of context to make the case that
the economy is good or bad.
Now, let me show you a couple of different
things here.
This is a chart of the labor participation
rate, as you can see.
This goes back before 1950.
I'll describe it to you.
It's not as high as it's ever been.
Right now, the labor participation rate is
between 62 and 63%.
In the late nineties, early 2000s, the labor
participation rate was 67%.
So right now, if you were one of the politically
partizan people that wants to say the economy
is bad, you go, we are a full five points
lower in terms of the labor participation
rate than we were 20 years ago.
It's terrible right now.
Okay.
That's one perspective.
However, if instead of looking at the rate
we look at the number of people working, which
is what that headline I showed you says you
would accurately be able to say there are
more people than ever working right now.
That being said, you would also have to figure
out if there are more people than ever not
working right now because of the growth of
the population.
So let me be very real with you.
Okay.
In order to figure out how the economy is
doing, you have to look at many factors and
you should be looking at the employment rate.
You should be looking at job creation.
It's useful to look at stock market performance
to a degree.
Consumer confidence.
Look at inflation.
Look at wages.
Look at export.
Import balance.
At trade balance.
There's a bunch of different things that we
would look at.
One of the problems with the labor participation
rate or the number of people working is how
it is composed.
So a lot of times right wingers love to say
the unemployment rate isn't accurate because
if you stop looking for work, you no longer
count as unemployed.
That's true, but that's always been the case.
That was the case when Reagan was president.
And those very same Republicans talked about
how great the unemployment rate was.
That's always the case.
That's a limitation of the of the measurement.
The problem with the labor participation rate
is sometimes when people aren't working, it's
because the economy is good.
I'm going to give you some examples.
Okay.
If you are a high school junior or senior
or in college, meaning you're like between
16 and 22 years old.
Okay.
If you're in college full time.
In these numbers, you show up as someone who's
not working, you show up as you're in the
not working part.
But the reason you might be able to afford
to go to college full time is because the
economy is good and your parents work and
they don't need you to work to help feed the
family.
You could also look at the inverse.
You could have a higher labor participation
because all of these people who could be in
college have to work because the economy is
so bad.
Their household with their parents needs more
income.
I'll give you another example.
Stay at home, parents.
Lower the labor participation rate.
But if the economy were really bad, a lot
of those stay at home parents would have to
go out and get a job.
So stay at home.
Parents make this number look worse, but it's
a sign that the economy is better.
I'll give you another example.
When people retire, they exit the labor force.
They show up on that not working side.
If the economy is good, more people can afford
to retire.
If the economy is bad.
More of those people who would like to retire,
can't they keep working?
You've got a higher labor participation, but
not because the economy is good, because it's
bad.
So you get the picture.
It's a very deceptive number by itself.
Republicans love using it.
What's the truth of the matter?
The truth of the matter is the economy is
pretty good right now.
The stock market is sort of stabilizing.
Inflation is coming down.
Job creation numbers are better than expected.
Unemployment's low.
Is it a perfect economy?
Of course not.
Is there suffering?
Is there poverty?
Is there hunger?
Of course there's all of those things.
But by the metrics we normally use, the economy
is doing pretty well now.
One last thing on this.
Joe Biden's approval rating does seem to be
responding to a lot of different things, but
it's basically been an increasing approval
rating since late July for Joe Biden.
So late July.
Biden's approval bottomed out.
It then spiked by early September.
And it's been just like a slow burn increase
to close to 44%.
Is 44% an amazing approval rating?
No.
In the modern era of hyper partizanship, is
it a typical approval rating for a president
who's doing the job well enough?
Yeah, it's sad that our standards are that
low.
But it is it's certainly no disaster.
And it will be interesting to see how that
impacts the coming two years.
So more people than ever working.
Is it the be all end all of judging the economy?
It is not.
But I hope you all give me credit.
I don't play the partizan games with the labor
force
participation rate.